[Musique]
maccione la musique me vive examiné mido
c'est la musique et kaoua riche citron
plein des voix
lawzi ben voilà le travail du pays la
bourdonnais paris
m
mama yemo trouve sautière nena pouvoir
maman est aux trousses des ménages
histoire
là tout ça m'a vraiment donné là
vraiment c'est mon phone qui m'a demandé
de pâte à 7 me ma vie de verbalise 7 me
pose cette ville a tout le temps pour
l'entente à thoune grand-père de
tradition il fait nous donnait la
dignité
ça nous tu vas l'air en france où il
faut me chante en créole tu vois et la
loi vraiment la vallée à la langue
créole comme média ou là où vraiment de
mener cause comme nous et nos clients
des riches nous dit tout à fait que nous
avons tout le temps
[Musique]
si la mode paradis
il a pas de moratoire
[Musique]
larry il a mis sa partie anglais doit
donc nos gains effet malgré sa non un
concept anouma marie de monti marche
trop bien
en effet créole anglais mama traduit cet
axe esprits en créole pour montrer
comment vont ils vivent comment mener
cause comme nous
[Musique]
t